foreign
we're gonna go to talk to Jill in Grand
Rapids what's up Jill
hi Dr John how are you good hey you
heard the first intro not so great huh
hey so good okay look into my future
with my 10 year old
[Laughter]
exactly except he may be in his 40s okay
so what's up how can I help
um well I'll just have a little bit of
backstory here
um I've been married for about 12 years
and my husband previously worked in
community mental health for over a
decade
and for the last five years he went into
private practice as a trauma-focused
therapist which he's amazing at and I've
never seen him so excited to go to work
and come home and excited to talk about
it
um so I'm really thankful for that
however I have noticed a little bit of a
shift in our relationship how we might
handle situations with the kids a little
bit differently
um and so I was just wondering if you
had any insight as to how to help
support romana's job make him feel like
I
I'm not against his job I just would
like my husband to be home when he's
home and not him to come home as a
therapist
you did an incredible
Central to Northern Michigan job
of painting a really messy situation in
as bright a colors as you can
and I know this because I've lived this
exact thing
it's hard isn't it
yeah
tell me more about it
um
it's hard because sometimes I feel like
nope you're saying really nice things
sometimes I feel
tell me what's happening
I'm being talked to in our conversations
like a client there you go
what does that mean
it makes me
it makes me feel
um
like I'm just another person
um
not supported not supportive for who I
am at times
and as though you're a person to be
fixed or a problem to be solved or a
series of
actions away from being the person you
are supposed to be whatever that means
just use listening to your language it's
very distancing language
like you and I could just have a
conversation and I would know you
interact regularly with somebody who
works in mental health and I've been
talking to you for about 90 seconds
um because everything is distance
focused all of your language has has
space in it from
the actual actor and what it's doing to
you
hear what I'm saying
um give me an example where you're not
being supported
um or give me a scenario play something
out for me
well when we're having particularly our
oldest child when we when there is a
situation and
um
we I I do something about it I say
something I
um do something about it
I'm not always getting the back up from
him
um are you getting some sort of clinical
explanation or he comes over the top of
you
um it'll
I don't feel like we're on the same page
as far as working with him on certain
things my my oldest has had a lot of
medical trauma um so he's really good at
putting that hat on to help him out and
kind of almost back him up instead of
backing me up and being a team when
we're working with our kids on something
this is going to sound bananas
but your son needs a dad more than a
trauma therapist and it that lives with
him
does that make sense
yeah and I know that you need a husband
more so than a living expert who's going
to guide Garden direct everything that
happens inside that little home
right what does the conversation look
like when you've talked to him about
this
um
it starts out okay
and
um
but many times it comes out in our
argument or heated discussions if you
will
um where I might say something and it
comes back to him as
I'm not good enough you don't like my
job
um
and it's very hard because he's an
internal processor and I'm outward so I
pretty much will say it and I don't
always
mean it to offend him it's just how I'm
working through something well he gets
he gets to choose whether he's offended
or not
yeah that's the choice he's making
um
I applaud you for speaking your needs
out loud now if you're rude or you're a
jerk or you're trying to throw grenades
at him that's another thing that doesn't
sound like that at all sounds like
you're saying things like I don't I'm
tired of being treated like a client
here or you're coming home after dealing
with kids trauma over and over and over
and you're bringing that that
brittleness and that edge and you want
to talk about it all the time and then
that leads into every interaction with
our kids is like a is a clinical
interaction like I need you to come home
and put that stuff down
um
that sounds like what you're doing more
than the other is that right
yeah
yeah
occasionally I hit him but other than
that
um no hitting
um
so here's the deal I won't get into my
specifics I don't want to make your
story about me other than to say I I was
him
I brought that home
and I wasn't a technically a trauma
counselor per se but I spent my nights
and weekends in hospitals with people
over and over and over and I spent my
days sitting with people who were
falling apart at the seams and who are
struggling to
reconcile with tough decisions they'd
made Etc
and then I brought it home I wanted to
talk about it and I talked to my wife
like she was dumber than me like I had
all the answers because I'd read some
article by the way psychological
articles are less than 50 percent
reproducible which means they're often
garbage they're trash
they're not anyway
that's an aside
um so here's the deal you have every
right it's let me say it this way it's
unethical for him
to wear his hat as a therapist inside of
his home
it's unethical
it's wrong it's against professional
ethics
he should not treat his child like a
therapist he shouldn't treat his wife
like a therapist he shouldn't treat his
son like a client or his wife like a
client or his friends at work or school
um I'm sorry his friends at church or in
the neighbors or at the wait
he should treat his clients like clients
it's like boxers Who come out of the gym
leaving their boxing gloves on and then
just deciding to punch people at home
that's just not you can't do that okay
here's the unfortunate thing and then
here's the the empowering thing the
unfortunate thing is you can't make him
take that hat off
okay that's a choice he has to make when
he decides to be a little more mature in
his professional ethics and when he gets
a little more comfortable in
differentiating his work life from his
home life he needs to figure that out
really quickly okay
you can
um stop responding to it
and this is where you have the right and
the opportunity to say with respect and
dignity and kindness hey um I'm not your
client and if you talk to me like your
client then I'm understanding that
you're choosing to end this conversation
and then he gets to choose and the first
time you do that your heart's going to
beat really fast probably gonna get
sweaty like it's gonna feel awkward and
weird and he might throw a fit up
against that boundary
what is that supposed to mean I don't
even know what you're talking about and
then you're gonna have to articulate it
very clear
okay very very clear when you talk to me
like this
my wife told me here I said I'm not
going to make it about me but I am my
wife said you have a very particular
tone when you talk to me or the kids
your jaw sets in a certain way you have
a body posture
that doesn't say with it says at or it
feels over
and she was very very specific
and it gave me some things to to work on
right I will not be treated like a
client I'm your wife
I get equal say we get equal insights
and we're going to do this thing this
parenting thing together have you all
ever gone out for lunch and just talked
about what what the end game is with
your oldest
oh yeah many times where's the
disconnect there
[Music]
is
he sees how I may
want to or choose to parent
um him in a situation
and see the he's seen the effects of
that in his job and so I think there's
some of that is there's the fear so be
be specific do you you get mad at your
kid and you yell and then your husband's
going to work every day dealing with
kids who are traumatized or do you hit
your kid like what's what's the thing
that your husband's responding to
I'm
I guess I'm a little bit more
my kid knows my buttons and so he pushes
them and I react to it okay I don't
always respond to it no I don't hit them
but I I may talk to them like I've told
you how many times
um or no you're not going to ride your
bike because last time you didn't tell
us where you were
and so what about that does a trauma
therapist feel like they need to
intervene on
um
I don't
I don't think he he will he doesn't say
hey look your mom said you can't ride
your bike he's like if he's gonna go
cool off let him go ride his bike
yeah that has absolutely nothing to be
nothing
with being trauma therapist
like you're destroying your relationship
with him because of A B C or D
or or
you're holding him accountable to
certain boundaries
to keep him safe
right
yeah
um some of it too is his background is
the his parents were hard on him that's
it right there so that I don't know if
that
here's the deal there is a there is a a
movement within the trauma therapy world
and here's why I'm feeling this like my
if you were looking watching me now like
my shoulders are tensed up right now I'm
having to breathe through this one
because I've done this and I see the
destructive nature this has in my home I
had in my home okay me treating my wife
and my kids like this
the second thing is is there is a
Insidious thread of support and help
through the trauma counseling movement
which I think is an incredible thing we
are identify I'd speak all over the
country on trauma I get it
um I get it more than most and it's a
huge deal and it affects Millions more
people who than people think they do
and
simply taking people who have been hurt
who've experienced big trauma acute
trauma secondary trauma
and
not wanting to make them any more
uncomfortable
is not the way forward
in fact it makes him least less
resilient and it reinforces that anxious
mechanism that keeps them spun up all
the time they have to be walked through
hard things that's the whole point of
trauma counseling and so I tell you that
to tell you
if there's never tension between a
parent and a child then the parent is
failing miserably in their job
what you have is not a trauma counselor
who's trying to be supportive here's
another thing that I mean I used to say
certain things to my kids to my son
especially when he was younger
when it came to discipline and my wife
who is a pedagogical expert
working with kids and she also had a
background of training with discipline
with young boys
she said hey if you do it like this this
is not helpful what you're trying to get
is this try this way instead
and what she had was a set of skills it
wasn't an undermining because she got
uncomfortable or nervous during an
engagement see the difference
so one is
um
I he feels uncomfortable and so he's
gonna jump in there and make this thing
make himself feel better by making you
feel small
another is hey I actually have some
expertise here and I'm going to talk to
you about it offline
because I I know your heart honey and I
know what you're trying to get this
young boy and I'm gonna I know a better
a quicker or better way to get there
that's a totally different proposition
but hear me say this is about him not
the Trump the trauma therapy is simply
he uses that to back to make excuses for
himself
and I'm sorry for that what you have to
do
is say here's what I will accept and
that might be you sitting down saying
um no more well I accept you
undermining me in front of our kids if
you have a problem with some of the
things I'm the way I've said something
the way I've I've reacted to something
then I asked you to respect me enough to
have that conversation offline and I
promise you that I will be willing to
listen if we do it in a respectful way
foreign
yes and sometimes he does say things and
sometimes he's just completely silent
okay and just allows it to get
I would say worse but get louder well
and that's what hey hold on I'm not
gonna step in so it's either he chooses
to do that or he chooses not to step in
at all right and I
you're not off the hook either
you've got to stop responding to kids
yeah they don't get that from you
is that fair
and you might need to be humble and
change a few things about how you're
approaching things
yeah is that fair
oh yeah my guess is the bigger component
here the umbrella over all of this is
your husband traffic's in trauma he
deals with trauma for a living
and he comes home disconnected from
himself
and he is unable to be present with his
family the people who love him the most
because literally to do the work he does
every day he has to unhook his soul from
himself
does that make sense
yeah and so what you're really asking
for is a husband to come home and be
present
and when husbands don't know how to come
home and be present they come home and
do work
they do jobs
like fix their wives and instruct their
children
see what I'm saying
yep
here's here's what I would do moving
forward I would I would come up with
your boundaries and be I can't express I
can't express this enough you got to be
super clear
when you say these things you are
choosing to end a conversation with me
because I am choosing to no longer be
talked to like that
if you have ways that you can teach and
coach me because you've got some
expertise in an area I would love to
hear it here's how and when I will hear
that
if I am finding myself reacting
I will ask that you will just walk by
here's what I asked my wife to do I
asked her to walk by and just put her
hand on my arm
just gently like this and she does she
did it for a couple of years and now I
don't react anymore because she was
catching me in the moment I could feel
oh there I am
and I was able to take a breath and stop
myself
and you Jill have to be intentional
about stopping being so reactive with
your kids
and not apologizing for having
accountability and boundaries this whole
thing feels like it's a mess it feels
like there's bigger relationship issues
at play than just the kids
and
I
he won't go but I think it's time to
probably go to marriage counselor
because I don't like the trajectory of
those so I'm just being honest with you
this ends
um in a mess
hopefully he'll go
and if he won't you can say I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go learn some new tools and
and ways to communicate
foreign
man
professional helpers
your family doesn't usually need your
expertise occasionally in a crisis
and I'm talking to police officers I'm
talking to swat officers I'm talking to
counselors I'm talking to nurses
they don't they rarely need your
expertise
but they need more than anything
is you
so don't hide behind your job and all
your knowledge
to show up
to show up